businesses in southern nevada are about
to see a hike in one of their bills the
southern nevada health district
approving an increase to their
environmental health fee christian
casadas joins us now with more on the
issue and also it really affects every
business in the valley that's right well
the southern nevada health district says
businesses haven't seen a boost to this
annual bill in over 10 years now to keep
up with inflation a 27 percent increase
was approved and that has struggling
businesses concerned they're trying to
do a game of catch up on their own
and we're paying the consequences
another expense angelica nielsen says to
add to their growing list of costs for
this 15 year old business of saharan
decatur
the pastry palace still recovering from
the pandemic now it's just one of many
businesses in the valley getting hit
with the new bill hike by the southern
nevada health district it makes a
difference
our customers complain to us all the
time why things
like why our cakes are more expensive
and it's like well everything that we
have to pay for is also going up this
week the southern nevada health district
approved a 27 percent hike to its
environmental health fee which is
expected to generate about 25 million
dollars in 2023 with an annual increase
up to 3 percent after here's a kind of a
breakdown just general fast food all the
permits that they may require you know
they'll go up 106 dollars so
you know you think about the years 365
days that's way less than a dollar a day
they say the fee helps pay for things
like inspections food operations and
compliance solid waste and consumer
health the fee revenue according to the
health district's presentation no longer
covering their expenses it's about 300
300 and something
so meaning it's gonna go up
around 100 and something dollars as
nielsen and her team continue to recover
from the pandemic she understands the
reason behind the hike it's only the
timing that's rough even if it increases
like whatever you can complain about it
but you still have to sign your check
well health district officials say this
fee will increase public safety as it
will help with staffing christian casa
is live local now